found that we actually could deliver co2
right into open air environment crops
and the crops will gobble up the co2 and
we get far higher yield increases higher
quality more fruit production with
tomatoes we actually did a hundred and
twenty percent increase in yield I mean
it was phenomenal not only are we
sequestering co2 and creating a market
for it but it improves that water use
efficiency of the crops by eighty ninety
a hundred percent and that's what the
sensors do for us so they pick up the
daily temperatures the wind the light
radiation and and all that feeds into a
algorithm and it says ok at any point in
time
put a prescriptive level of co2 out
there and the plants just thrive on it
so our system is designed to release the
co2 right where the light is incident to
the plant because that it's it's the
light and the gas that are interacting
with each other right it's there up
taking the carbon and the sunlight
through photosynthesis converts it into
carbohydrates and sugars our core values
are have fun be agile be innovative boom
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan sock young we are
still at the new s summit the world's
leading cannabis tech conference and we
are now sitting down with Stuart
Erickson what's up yeah I having a great
show here really excited to be here on
your TV program and want to talk a
little about co2 and egg gas yes thank
you again for coming on we greatly
appreciate it and a gas ask Stuart said
is what he's building since 2013 so it's
been five years and founder and CEO and
also we have quite a bit to unpack about
this because this is not just about
cannabis although that is where it's
been the last like year or so focus the
let's start off in like 2013 talking
about how you guys started optimizing
agricultural crop yields for peppers and
tomatoes and I'll pass you the mic and
you can take over well sure it all
started as kind of a vision of creating
a market for co2 and we've been working
with some of the world leading people on
climate change and everybody kind of
concurs that in order to have a solution
there has to be a market for co2 an app
market as agriculture and I'm the man
that happened to have picked up on this
so we did a number of research trials
involving UC Davis Fresno State
University
the USDA out in San Joaquin Valley and
found that we actually could deliver co2
right into open air environment crops
and the crops will gobble up the co2 and
we get far higher yield increases higher
quality more fruit production and with
tomatoes we actually did a hundred and
twenty percent increase in yield I mean
it was phenomenal and the byproduct this
whole thing that really starts to get
exciting for the state of California and
other nations not only are we
sequestering co2 and creating a market
for it but it improves the water use
efficiency of the crops by 80 90 a
hundred percent so it really ultimately
can be a big water conservation
technology so the change there so how
are how is spring the little bit of co2
onto the tomato plant how does that both
increase the the yield up to 120 percent
more and how does it de sequester co2
and then also how does it decrease the
water use sure sure so like with the
with the tomato project where all these
universities in the USDA was involved
they they went they dug up the plants
and so while we had this hundred percent
plus yield increase on on the fruit what
they found is the the plants absorb the
carbon dioxide through the leaves and
they take that in a reallocated into
root structure and soil carbon so it's
building soil tilth
microbial activity all the things that
like an organic farmer wants to see and
the co2 is considered organic right it's
not a chem
it's the carbon building block that all
plants need and the other thing that's
interesting then is the huge water loss
if you think all a San Joaquin Valley
it's through the leaves of all the
orchards and their vineyards and the
crops out there and the co2 controls
those little stomata openings where the
gas exchange occurs so when we do a tiny
bit of elevation of the co2 there's a
huge reduction of water water loss
through that plant so it just implants
impacts the plants physiologically in a
really great method it's the co2 that
goes down they absorb through the leaves
down to the root structure that then
makes it so that the plant needs to less
water to be able to thrive not exactly
the the have more access to nutrients
and the water that is there but this
damata openings their solids and see
these little openings on the underside
of the plant of the leaves and that's
where the carbon goes in one molecule in
10,000 molecules of water out and so
when we give it a tiny bit more of the
co2 that stomata opening closes and now
the water loss plummets out of the leaf
of that plant I kind of compare it to
somebody when they're like climbing
Mount Everest and they become anemic at
high elevations right that's kind of
what's going on with the plants almost
every day cuz the way they evolved was
in a really high carbon dioxide
environment and now today there's only
400 parts per million so the plants not
only like the co2 but they thrive on the
co2 and they allows them to use a lot
less fresh water to go through the
photosynthetic process is that we're
talking as plants evolved over the last
billion plus years that that we have had
a time period of 800 parts per million
of co2 or something much greater
and then plants were thriving more kind
of having more co2 to pull from
so you grow with and now having it back
down 300 now 400 ppm is just much so you
just so you give them that little boost
of co2 and then that increases the yield
yes so the the company you know is
really what we were talking about
earlier is we're really mission driven
we we realize though well let me go slow
because we're mission driven it's really
allowed me to track some top business
talent people in California and other
areas that country that wants to we want
to be involved with you we want to be
involved with this and because the
environmental benefits and we realized
that we have to build a company right so
we have to be profitable and that's
what's allowed me to build a great
management team and attract financing
but what happened is once California
passed prop 64 we had a hard
conversation it's like well are we gonna
you know screw around with tomatoes and
almonds over here in Central Valley are
we gonna go have a conversation with the
cannabis guys and we did that we held
some roundtables found out the people
were super great and the conversation
was really a hundred and eighty degrees
because the cannabis guys were doing
this in their college dorm rooms 20
years ago right and they're like you can
do this outdoors or in a greenhouse or
nopales and we're go yeah here's all the
university data on the peppers and the
tomatoes and they they're like we're in
right so we ran this since October last
year we picked a really reputable
cannabis grower up in Ukiah California
and we ran trials very similar it's
exactly equal all the nitrogen
fertilizers the planting the varietals
look even the crew that managed that
grow site and especially the irrigation
water versus the same who pulses with
co2 introduced with our carbocation
service and last fall we got a validated
report with the CPA firm out of Santa
Rosa that pegged it at 27% yield on that
fall harvest and now this lasts a month
ago they did their second harvest this
year they
got over 50% increase and when you look
at the the price per pound at a thousand
bucks a pound in getting 30 more pounds
per hoophouse the numbers get really
staggering in a hurry so we are now
building these more high-tech systems
they have little low voltage sensors we
deploy the sensors out in the field
they're wireless and that the data
really allows us to drive these systems
so what it does is it puts just a
prescription amount of co2 out there
just the right amount of co2 in the
right place at the right time the
cannabis growers can go through their
normal function all year long it's on a
glider system so they can install mesh
trellis do their harvesting replant
reset the system and go through another
cycle so if we get in their way we're in
trouble and the system is all designed
to do that plus they get a grower user
interface on their phone so they're
gonna get data out of their grow rooms
that they otherwise don't have so it's
eventually it's organic and we think
there'll be some logical migrations in
the market you know for us to either go
right over the fence into the orchards
or vineyards with the technology or into
other geographies but right now we're
really focused on building the company
and and a management team and the
capacity the supply chain all the things
that go with building the company so
that this broader vision that all of us
at the company hold can become a reality
oh man this is so cool so the tiny bit
of added co2 to cannabis even outdoors
can increase showing right now 50%
increase in crop yield yes so the
project where we just pulled that 50%
off was what is called a hoop pulse so
they had they have 11 hoop houses that
this test farmer were working well it's
a commercial operation in Mendocino
County but so several of the hoop houses
were held without co2 for
that we're on the fourth oh yeah exactly
control we work because the farmers all
want to know - plus we needed that -
exactly so the rest of the community can
also benefit from it good point so and
and the sidewalls were all opened up the
end caps were all opened up so really
this last grow cycle that they did only
had a shade cloth across the top of the
plants they'll breeze everything just
blows right through there and that's
what the sensors do for us so they pick
up the daily temperatures the wind the
light radiation and and all that feeds
into a algorithm and it says okay at any
point in time
put a prescriptive level of co2 out
there and the plants just thrive on it
in fact I would say I was at the farm
last year when the solar eclipse
happened and it was like oh there goes
the system would shut off and then
turned right back on again during the
solar eclipse yeah it's pretty funny
that's good work so okay we teach us
about this this part seems interesting
to me so you have sensors detecting all
the variables and that is of course very
important to measure the dynamic state
of the of the the grow and then there is
a prescriptive dose of co2 so the
algorithms say okay it's right now it's
the right time maybe my question is then
how do you know it's the right time how
often is the right time yeah it's it's
well exactly so some of this you're
getting in the secret sauce of the
company but we've we've we've we we've
got some sophisticated instrumentation
that we've been using to to measure you
know how these plants respond we we
don't have all the answers yet today - I
mean not only from species to species is
it going to vary but also even we think
with in cannabis there's a lot of
different varietals so we think they'll
even be variations within the varietals
in in how the produce with the co2 and
how they react with the other variables
like light and temperature so we don't
have all the answers but we're getting a
handle on some of that stuff
so it's really an exciting opportunity
for the company we you know it's much
different for tomatoes and peppers than
it is for cannabis or is this somewhat
similar there's actually the tomatoes
physiologically are fairly similar to a
cannabis plant so that one you might
actually see some similarities other
crops like you know the almonds or these
things that are really desert plants
you're gonna see some different heat
thresholds with those plants but one
thing we do know is that the co2 really
bumps up the heat tolerance of the
plants as well oh yeah so and this is
where we think we're picking up big
yield increases right climates to them
and then they can withstand oh yeah and
and with the warming that's going on out
in the Central Valley I mean it's really
well documented out in San Joaquin that
the temperature right now they're
getting like I think they're predicting
60 days excess heat days a year now so
we really think eventually we can help
those guys out there not only with their
organic production but also with their
water situation so right exactly and the
cannabis guys they tend to be more in
the mountains you know the less areas
with less air pollution so you know
there's a different set of environmental
factors
everywhere you go kind of like what the
wine industry they have the Appalachians
they're doing the same thing so there's
all these little micro climates and that
affects our technology and how it
performs I was again thinking about how
cool it is that you have banded together
like scientists with environmentalists
with agricultural agriculture is farmers
that that banding together these groups
and now with cannabis as well with the
medicine that is so cool I like that a
lot and I think that's what really
resonates what you were saying earlier
this mission-driven position that you
hold all right so
that's so interesting to me what other
cool patterns have you found like
increasing co2 we'll make it with Stan
greater heat have you found other cool
patterns like that I guess if I add one
last thing for the cannabis guys in
particular it was a concern for us is of
course how does it affect that quality
of the product because for the the
quality that bud the the the terpenes
and the THC content and you know the
chemistry is really important to these
guys and so at these farms that we've
been doing is we've been harvesting out
of the control harvest you know the same
part of the plant in the sea obligation
Service hoops and running everything
into Sonoma lab works and so we've been
spending quite a bit of money to monitor
the quality of the product coming on and
we're we're finding that we're either
you know slight uptick but generally I'm
on parity so we're really pleased with
that because there's no deterioration in
the quality of the product that was a
really big deal well we have seen and
we're gonna spend some of our R&D
dollars we're finding that we were
seeing some less mold and of course mold
and mites and some of these issues that
the farmers have particularly with
cannabis and other crops we think that
we can start to address some of those
issues that organically without spraying
chemicals and that could be a really big
deal for for the industry so we're you
know we don't we don't have all the
answers yet we got right now we've got
more questions and answers but you know
we're the growers are coming to us and
they're going hey you know can you help
with this and we're okay one thing at a
time you guys ready right because we've
got to build the company so but we've
been lucky we've been able to attract
really great people which makes it fun
you know our core values are have fun be
agile be innovative we're very employee
centric you know it's about the people
and we're safety centric so we've got
some really good core values
and we're doing longitudinal tests on on
consuming the increased two peppers and
tomatoes and cannabis that have
increased in co2 not exactly sure what
you're asking them if I'm consuming
tomatoes that are that have had a gas if
I'm consuming those Tomatoes like once a
week or once every couple days and I'm
doing that for a year it's so hard to
isolate variables and try and figure it
out but there shouldn't shouldn't be any
health issues have you are you concerned
about yeah no so we won we've seen a lot
more healthier more vigorous plants so
just the overall health of the plants is
enormous ly better so you know we think
that they're more disease resistant more
pest resistant so so we like that aspect
of it but there is like one study out I
think was maybe run in Japan that found
there was some site downtick and the
zinc content and there there's so
there's a couple studies out there
independent studies from our company
that said there's slightly less zinc in
in the grain or crop we ran everything
through the universities and family are
spot on
you know we tested Brix sugar content to
the plants and shelf-life of the of the
fruit I mean we ran we had the same
questions right I mean right so ya know
and we find and same with the cannabis
it's like no we got to check the full
spectrum microbials everything on this
to see where it's at and so far we've
been we've been in great shape on that
but there is some other things that the
one I've noted and we're gonna continue
to look at that when we go back to the
food crops is you know what's what's
going on with the zinc content don't
have an answer for that I've got a
question right now about that so yeah
yeah I'm happy that you're asking so
many questions we love asking powerful
questions on the show and that's really
important that you carry that mentality
of having tons of questions and wanting
to do the raw science get the good data
get as much data as you can collect
on it all right so that's been that's
been pretty good so now okay now it's
2018 you're moving moving quickly moving
forward with Ag now what percentage of
your time is going to be dedicated
towards cannabis versus the tomatoes and
peppers what percentage of resources
were you looking at yeah right now for
2018 2019 and we were a hundred percent
focus on cannabis were we it looks like
the sales of the company are going to
ramp up pretty quickly in the next six
months and so we're gonna have some
operational challenges from a business
standpoint to deliver on systems and to
make sure you know with our customers we
want to you know under promise and over
deliver and so we want to make sure that
we're building the organization and
doing all the right things from a
business standpoint and from a financing
standpoint we've got a really great
board of directors we've got a good
science advisory board and we've got a
really good management team so those
kind of issues we should be able to work
through pretty well we use it what's
called the entrepreneurs operating
system which is a really cool platform
where we all get our weekly stones and
our monthly rocks and you know so we're
doing some fun stuff that really keeps
us on focus and on task to develop the
business and then you know we're gonna
make some logical steps as they're
presenting themselves to us about how
we're gonna expand the markets you know
so we got to kind of rate those and
figure out how we're gonna manage
because every time you try to take a
step like that it consumes resources so
you know a lot of companies have
faltered because they make the either
overextend or they don't have the amount
of capital to to finance that so there's
there's going to be some operational
issues that we're gonna have to be very
careful you know to to build a good
business yeah change the tech stack how
do you improve the technology stack
because right now you are spraying for
gently from the side of the crop or from
the top and then how are you yeah and
then how is that being changed over time
and
or this house the software updating
overtime etc well the good news for us
is we're going to be getting gathering a
lot of data and we see value and that
data come on out of these grow sites so
the data is going to be valuable to us
so we're going to continue to mine that
data and try to improve the systems we
already are have filed you know our
first u.s. patent just got issued we
have a whole patent portfolio I mean I'm
already looking at gen 3 Gen 4 and Gen 5
we we see that this thing is really
gonna migrate and improve and that
there's some other things that can
happen with the systems and the
technology so we're on that we're filing
patents we're just going to file our
first you know PCT which is an
international patent next week yeah yeah
so it's a little bit it's a little bit
crop dependent you know the trees
obviously are need the co2 way up here
ground crops need the co2 down here so
cannabis is an interesting challenge
because it grows really fast and it gets
pretty tall so our system is designed to
release the co2 right where the light is
incident to the plant because it's it's
the light and the gas that are
interacting with each other right it's
there up taking the carbon and the
sunlight through photosynthesis converts
it into carbohydrates and sugars so it's
really important that we get that gas
right to the area of the plant where all
this photosynthetic the photosynthetic
activity is going on so our system is
like on a little ratchet glider system
we've got these clickers and so it
ratchets up they know their manual but
oh yeah so when the crew when their crew
of you know 10 guys comes in to install
my trellis for instance it goes click
like a click goes right up gets out of
their way they can install a mesh
trellis or harvest the crop and then it
just glides right back down onto the
baby plants that they just replanted so
it's really key that we don't interrupt
the agronomic function of these farmers
because these guys they work really hard
right and it's like no these
work hard it has to be it's what I call
it kind of elegantly simple and yet
dependable so and then the sensors do
the rest of the work so it's all
automated you know eventually is
probably even some room for some aai in
this situation but we haven't gotten
that that advanced in it are the sensors
then also seeing how high the plant is
growing so that the system knows how
high to go up and spray the co2 where
the photosynthesis is happening we we
have sensors in the array that can
monitor that so we're clearly looking at
that capability yeah so much about the
tech stack that I'm finding really
interesting and we have a couple other
friends that are doing robotics in
agriculture and and also working on
yields in agriculture so this is really
fun and I'm excited to see where where
this goes in the future what are you
most looking forward to regarding the
future of cannabis in the future of
Agriculture well I I think water is
gonna continue to be a huge challenge
globally for cannabis growers it already
is to get their permits I mean the water
is a huge issue for the cannabis guys
and I think it's going to really
intensify in other areas so I see that
water issue is an ongoing problem and
you know and just with global population
is going to be continuing pressure on
the food supplies and particularly you
know look at like San Joaquin Valley and
our you know the salad bowl these areas
are really getting subject to higher
temperatures so it's it's throwing some
of the the seasonal growing's regimes
kind of out of balance and our so I
think we can possibly help you know
level some of that out for these guys
and then the whole idea you know to fit
in with California with the renewable
energy mandate which you know you have
biofuels that produce a lot of co2 of
closing that carbon cycle and creating a
market for the carbon you know that that
really is something
or is the long-term vision of the
company and we think we see a path right
now so cannabis is the first step and
then we move into these other areas and
then the broader vision of the company
you know we can get to these 30,000 foot
kind of conversations but wow you know
we actually did something for the next
generation yeah I'm also so interested
in how to tweak the variables of
sunlight soil composition the co2
there's so many of these variables to
tweak to see how to maximize crop yields
just in the evolutionary perspective we
were just talking about what was
happening millions or hundreds of
millions of years ago with crop yields
what was optimizing the efficiency what
have we lost in terms of information
since then so I'm really happy that we
put it into that perspective as well
stood this has been so much fun what a
pleasure thanks a lot for having me on
the show
awesome it's been super fun a gasps we
have the link in the bio go check it out
also go and build the future go create
go manifest your destiny thank you for
tuning in much love SIA
[Music]